But really, I think that people make a big deal about that you date younger men.
I don't think that should be...
Okay, first of all, stop.
Okay.
I'm not, I don't date younger men.
It's not like you have to be younger.
It's not about that.
I just meet people and then, if I go out with them, I go out with them...
...and if I like them, I like them; if I don't, I don't.
It's about the person.
You know what I mean?
It's about who they are.
It has nothing to do with age.
I'm straining because I can't talk.
Don't strain your voice.
Does it sound like I'm screaming?
Take care of your instrument.
I'm not yelling.
No.
No, but there's this thing because I dated Beau and he was younger.
And that was the first guy I ever dated who was younger than me.
But then I got labeled...
Yeah.
...right away.
And then, you know,...
...that was it.
You just happen to meet people.
I agree, that's why I said there's a thing about it.
I don't think you should, I don't think age should be a thing at all.
For me, it isn't.
If there's somebody older, they're older.
If they're younger, they're younger.
It doesn't matter.
It's just whether or not I'm attracted to them or not,...
...attracted to their spirit, their soul.
Whatever.
Whatever, their energy.
Their body, whatever.
Yes!